well it may not be the most normal  Memorial Day weekend but people are  still expected to hit the road this  weekend NHP is teaming up with CHP to  crack down on reckless driving this is  on i-15 between the California and  Nevada State Line on Friday 130  citations were issued 122 of them were  for speeding  due to the current circumstances it's  unknown how busy the roads will be but  both agencies will be on the highway  ensuring motorists are driving safely  travelers are also reminded that the  stretch from prim to st. Rose Parkway is  designated as a zero tolerance zone  that's even the most minor traffic  infraction will be enforced during the  holiday weekend